hello everyone and welcome to another
most interesting game from round one of
this year's Tata steel chess tournament
it is the winner of the Tata steel chess
tournament 2022 Edition Yan P Forest
versus Sala Fu if you remember it was a
pretty crazy tournament where Magnus had
a good run but he lost to yeno and then
he ended up one point behind Jordan v
Forest uh but in the end the tournament
was tied between Jordan and Anish giri
they went into tie breaks and after two
games of tie breaks uh it was still a
draw and and then Jordan was able to
take down Anish in Armageddon so he won
very nicely even though Anish almost won
that one and he won the 2023 Edition H
but now he faces against a most devious
opponent ala fua also one of the
participants of the 2024 candidates
tournament and um yeah it's I mean it's
a great matchup it's a great fight let's
see what happened here so Jordan has the
white pieces and he opened with Pawn to
E4 we have Pawn to E6 alza goes for the
French defense uh sorry about that uh
and Jordan strikes in the center with
Pawn to D4 we have Pawn to D5 and Knight
to C3 and usually Bishop to B4 is played
here and by usually I mean it is the
most common move here but Knight to F6
the classical French is also very much
played uh and now just Bishop to G5
where you have two very good options you
could play Bishop to E7 uh or you could
capture on e4 right away sometimes H6 is
played and the difference is for example
if you play Bishop D E7 let's say
something like E5 Knight to E4 you can
simply trade here and then a trade
occurs on E7 and it's a fine position
you can play this but ala prefers a
different line D captures on e4 at least
for this game Knight captures on e4 and
now Bishop to E7 where you could capture
with the bishop which is uh by far the
most popular option or you could capture
with the Knight these two are considered
the most popular trying to keep material
on the board with Knight to C3 hasn't
been proven to be all that great for
white and and the thing is if you play
Bishop captures then you go into the
morovich line of this um French setup
where G captures on F6 is played and
this is very very tricky uh but it is
the most common idea however Jordan
decides to trade everything on F6 so
Knight captures Bishop captures Bishop
captures and queen captures and now as
the D4 Pawn is already attacked by the
queen you can't play something like
Queen to F3 so here we have Knight to F3
Castles by alza and now Queen to D3
yordan announces that he will be castl
Queen side uh Bishop to D7 and now Queen
to E3 making room for the light core
Bishop on D4 but now the D4 Pawn is
nicely defended so okay Knight to C6 and
we have queenside castles and now there
is a game where Knight to B4 was played
and Knight to B4 is one of the top uh
moves recommended by the engine but
Alesa goes for Rook F to d8 and
depending on how long you allow the
engine to Crunch the numbers it will say
or Knight to B4 is the best or Rook F to
d8 is the best and it is now as of move
11 that we have a completely new game so
as we have castles on opposite sides of
the board of course you know that Jordan
will try to play on the king side
whereas ala will try to attack on the
queen side and here we have Pawn to C3
of course you want to strengthen your
your D4 pawn and ala immediately uh
fights against that Knight to D7 he
makes room for the pawn to be pushed to
C5 and the Knight can be REM maneuvered
to D5 or F5 with Tempo Jordan's Queen is
on E3 so Queen to E5 Jordan offers a
queen trade and now Bishop to A4
attacking the rook and now uh ala's idea
is that if B3 then he can play something
like Bishop to C6 or maybe he even
wouldn't play this as you'll see what
happened in the game and now if Queens
get traded off let's say captures
captures you don't want to have your
Pawn structure ruined so let's say
Knight E1 and now B5 stopping Pawn to C4
and you will have this backwards Pawn on
C3 that can later be attacked with
Knight to D5 and it will be a maybe not
a permanent weakness but it will be a
weakness for a very long time time so
instead Jordan goes Rook to E1 and now
Queen to G6 all it is stops the queen
trade and threatens Checkmate on C2 so
how does Jordan stop this Pawn to B3 we
have Bishop back to d8 again Bishop to
C6 seems to be the most logical move uh
just putting pressure on this diagonal
but Ala plays Queen to E8 I have no idea
what the what the plan is probably uh it
has been thoroughly analyzed that Bishop
to C6 doesn't really yield any advantage
for black so Bishop to is is a long-term
plan for ala and okay Queen G5 again
offering the queen trade and now Knight
to D5 putting pressure on that C3 pawn
and now uh you have to decide how to
deal with this if you can play C4 that's
going to be great for you but if you
play C4 now uh then a queen trade
happens and after captures captures
Knight to B4 you have all sorts of
weaknesses here your um A2 Pawn is
attacked the D4 Pawn is attacked and
there's just no good way uh to to tackle
all of this if if you play Pawn to A3
for example then Knight to C6 again puts
pressure on your Pawn you can't Advance
it to D5 so it would be a pretty pretty
bad move and if of course Knight to F3
you can defend it once but it's attacked
twice so that's kind of the idea here so
Jordan instead decides to trade first
queen captures H captures and just play
King to B2 so he defends the pawn here
but now alza goes Rook a to C8 and after
Bishop to C4 he strikes in the center
with Pawn to C5 uh dcap on C5 is played
Rook captures on C5 and now Rook to
E5 uh preventing the knight from moving
as The Rook on C5 is undefended H but
alza finds this beautiful Pawn to B5
move and now how do you how do you play
this the problem is even though you
don't really want to give up your Bishop
for Knight if you go back with something
like Bishop D2 this C3 Pawn is just weak
and uh it seems like you can't capture
it right away because if Rook captures
then you capture on D5 and pick up the
rook and if the Knight captures of
course The Rook hangs on C5 uh but
there's this nasty F6 move attacks the
rook and now after Rook captures here
you will be able to gobble up the C3
pawn and okay you can play something
like Rook to C1 but now Pawn to B4 and
okay Rook to A6 go goes after the A7
Pawn but now G5 threatens G4 to kick
away the Knight and bring the Rook over
to D2 and if H3 you will play King to H7
even give up the A7 pawn and now Bishop
to G6 and I'll look at this position the
bishop here absolute monster then Knight
on C3 is Untouchable the rook's
controlling C and D file this would be
very very hard to play with white so
instead Jordan decides okay I can't
really keep the bishop I have to give up
the bishop for Knight he plays Bishop
captures on D5 Rook captur Rook C
captures on D5 if anyone is listening uh
you know without watching Rook captures
and Rook captures on D5 and now just
Pawn to C4 uh Jordan gets rid of the
weakness on C3 and advances the pawn
also threatens to create a past Pawn so
B captures on C3 B captures and now Rook
to F5 ala prevents the knight from
moving as the F2 Pawn will fall and he's
looking forward to E4 E5 E4 kicking away
the Knight and Rook captures on F2 so
how can Jordan fight against this well
Rook to D1 he wants to bring the Rook
over to d8 and if all it is gets too
playful with the King side pawns then
maybe he can just start advancing his
own past Pawn to Victory uh King to f8
and now Rook to d8 Ala advances the pawn
to to E5 uh King to B3 now we have Pawn
to E4 and now just Knight to D2 so the
King was moved so Rook captures on F2
does not pin the Knight and if um ala
captures on F2 Jordan Will capture on e4
so King to E7 first improving the
position uh Rook to A8 now threatening
to pick up the A7 Pawn with Tempo and
alza plays this beautiful Bishop to C6
move attacks the rook and also says you
can have the A7 Pawn uh even with check
okay Jordan captures it it's the best
move uh King to to D6 and now Rook to A6
pinning the bishop again if Rook
captures an F2 Knight can capture on e4
since the the bishop is pinned uh but
King to
C7 ala just nicely on pins Rook to A7
with check and now King to d8 also the
F7 Pawn is defended so you don't have to
worry about that and E4 Pawn is defended
so now alza is just threatening Rook
captures an F2 and then the E Pawn
becomes a pass pawn and then all of the
king side pawns might fall as well uh
and here uh if you play Rook to A6 okay
let's say you try something like this
and then Rook captures on F2 uh Rook
captures on C6 you will Capt on D2 and
the past E Pawn will just be winning so
instead you to play King to C3 you have
to bring your king closer to the soon to
be pass pawn and now Rook captures an F2
Knight to B3 uh preparing to bring the
Knight to D4 and Ala plays Pawn to E3
and this video will feature two pause
the video moments uh one of them starts
now because only one move here uh
prevents uh the Ala from winning the
game so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only and absolute best
move for Jordan while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
Knight to D4 as that is the move you
already played but it is not the correct
move that solves this position the only
way to solve this is King to D three
yeah you just bring the king closer and
that's it seems like uh an easy thing to
do but not when you're playing Galera
and it's not that it was time trouble or
anything both of them had plenty of time
that's why I'm not mentioning the clocks
H but the point is that now after you
play E2 now you play King to D2 of
course you stop promotion and after
Bishop captur on G2 now you play Knights
to D4 and you're not even uh in a rush
to pick up the E2 Pawn you're just
guarding the C6 Square you want to start
advancing your own pawn and now if let's
say King to E8 uh C5 five you will play
Bishop back to D5 and now Pawn to C6 and
now after you bring a Queen into the
game doesn't really matter uh Rook will
capture on A2 and of course white does
not want to trade white will play
something like Rook B7 you bring the
Rook to A8 and you've uh you've rid
yourself of this uh nuisance on E2 that
was the the the pass pawn and now you
just start advancing your king and uh
well all in all it's a draw even even
something like this let's say Rook to A2
with check King to E3 Rook to E3 check
King to D2 and now you can even play
Bishop captures and C6 because the three
pawns will be uh enough
to just get get a draw here you will
also eliminate the H2 pawns so three
pawns against zero pawns will be a
sufficient uh compensation for the for
the extra piece uh but instead Jordan
played Knight to D4 right away and he
missed one move that alza can play in
order to make his position a winning one
so once again feel free to pause the
video and win the game now for alira
while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on stopping King to
D3 and the only way to do that
successfully is to play Bishop to E4
especially congratulations if you didn't
go for for the pawn here Bishop to E4 is
the way to do it as now the king is cut
off from the D3 square and from the D2
square and now the the pawn is just
Unstoppable Jordan started pushing his
own pass Pawn but now ala just played
Rook to D2 of course not E2 if you play
E2 then King to D2 stops the pawn but
after Rook to D2 there is no more move
that you can play and he was in this
position on move 37 that yordan V fores
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here problem is now that
whatever you play let's say you play
Pawn to C6 just Rook captures on D4 and
that's it once you capture The Rook E2
uh there's no stopping the pawn White's
on A2 Pawn is in the way and uh that's
pretty much it you can give a check but
it doesn't matter the the the there are
no more checks there are no more tricks
you can capture the bishop and then E1
Queen with check and you know if
something like this you can easily pick
up the Rook but you don't have to rush
it it's completely winning as white has
zero counterplay here uh so yeah very
nicely played by both of them uh Jordan
really played well he he got rid of his
C3 weakness was able to advance it to C4
he played a great game but he made one
one inaccuracy or well we can even call
this a blunder uh that allowed ala to
win the game King to D three was
essential here once Knight at D4 was
played it was all ala needed to take the
win here and against a player like ala
former 2800 one mistake is all it takes
for uh for him to win the game so great
game by both of them but it is alza who
is a triumphant here and with the black
pieces no less and for those of you who
haven't seen the previous videos from
round one I will mention some of the
stand some of the pairings and the
standings uh So currently we have Yanni
pishi on one point who defeated Max far
alzan one point who defeated Jordan
Anish giri defeated women's world
champion Jun and Wei who defeated
Alexander donchenko with half a point we
have Ding and makulu abdat and prananda
vidit gujrati and GES and for for the
moment on zero points Yan F Forest
Alexander donchenko Max faram and ju Wun
and the pairings for round two are as
follows abdat will face prand Yan pishi
will face Jun Anish giri will face vit
Wei will face GES alza will face par
makul ding Len will face donchenko and
Jordan fforest will face Max vedam so
those are the run two pairings we'll
check out the the most interesting one
and as usual I'm very much looking
forward to your hashtag suggestion uh
for what games to follow and also if you
have any nice games from the Challenger
section also use use hashtag suggestion
and I will do my best to take a look at
those maybe if the round will not be so
interesting in the master section or
maybe even Tata steel Masters is
finished then I will uh check out some
of the games from the Challenger section
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by
Ala uh you know as as we've expected
from from a candidate I would like to
thank Welsh fan Mark Henley Brennan
Michael Maes Frank banner and best
content maker for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check
through my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day